All right.
So, as we've seen in
the previous clip,
another way that initial
conditions may matter
is if a chain has a
periodic structure.
There are many ways of
defining periodicity.
Some of them are more
mathematical than others.
Let us consider one of the most
intuitive ways of doing that.
So here is the definition.
The states in a
recurrent class are
periodic if they can be
lumped together, or grouped,
into several subgroups so that
all transitions from one group
lead to the next group.
So what does that really mean?
Let us try to parse out this by
looking at the given example.
So here we would
have a situation,
a structure of a diagram,
in which d is equal to 2.
Whenever you are at a given
time in a state in that group,
in the next transition
you will go to that group.
And if you are in that group,
at the next transition,
you will go to that group.
So in some sense,
there is periodicity,
and there is somewhat of
a deterministic behavior,
according to this transition.
But there is also
some randomness left.
We can be in any of these
states within that sub-group.
But one thing that
is for sure is
that whenever, at
a given time, you
are into one of
these states, here,
in that group, if
the Markov chain has
this specific structure,
in the next transition
you will transition to
one of the states, here.
And the next transition
after, you will go back here.
So essentially, if
your Markov chain
started in one of these states
here, at time n equals zero,
then at time n equals
1, it would be here.
And then at time n equals
2, it would be here.
Times them into 3, and
so on and so forth.
So every time you would
have an even number,
then you are guaranteed
that the Markov chain will
be in one of these states, here.
Clearly, with this
kind of structure,
it is impossible to have
convergence of the steady state
probabilities.
This is another
example where you
would have a structure
of a diagram in which you
have a period of 3, here.
So in that case
here, d equals 3.
So here again, if you are in
one of these states at a given
time, then at the next time
the following transition
will guarantee to bring
you in that group.
And during the next transition
you will go to that group.
And then again,
here, and again you
have this kind of behavior
in a very systematic way.
So if you started here
at time n equals 0,
you would be in that group,
here, at times n equals 1.
And you would be
here at n equals 2.
And again, n equals 3 here, n
equals 4, n equals 5, 6, 7, 8.
And you see the pattern.
If you look at any
time in the future,
if the time is of the form
3 times k for any k greater
than or equal to 0,
you're guaranteed
that your chain will be
in one of these states.
Otherwise, it will
be here, or here.
So here again, you do
not have convergence
of the steady states,
because if you
are told that you started in
one of the states here, then
you know that whenever
you have a time that
is the form 3k plus
1 you will be here.
And so the probability
of being here would be 0.
All right, so we have been able
to explain a little bit what
a periodic state is,
using this definition.
Now given a Markov
chain, how can we
tell whether a Markov
chain is periodic or not?
There are, in fact,
systematic ways
of doing it mathematically.
But usually within the types of
examples we see in this class--
most of them, these
will be easy to see-- we
just eyeball the chain and we
tell whether it is periodic
or not.
So let us see if it is that easy
to do, and consider that chain,
here.
OK, so let's see.
Is this chain periodic or not?
I will give you a couple of
seconds to think about it.
Now I'm going to
help a little bit.
I'll just decide that
this one will be red,
and this one will be red.
Now I'm asking
the same question.
What do you think?
Well, from the
structure it is clear
that this Markov
chain is periodic
and has a period of d equals 2.
In some sense, the
red state, here,
could be one of these groups.
These are the red ones.
And the white, here,
would be those, here.
And it is clear, if you
look at this diagram,
that whenever you are in a red
state, at the next transition
you are guaranteed to
be in a white state.
From this one, you
will be in white.
will be in the white.
From this one , as well.
And from this one, as well.
And whenever you are in a white
state, this one, this one,
this one, or this one,
at the next period
you are guaranteed
to be in a red state.
So this tells you
that sometimes it
is not that easy to
eyeball and decide
if the Markov chain
is periodic or not.
If you have, for example,
lots of, lots of states,
you might have some trouble
doing this exercise.
On the other hand, something
very useful to know.
Sometimes, it's extremely easy
to tell that the chain is not
periodic, even if you
have a lot of states.
What is that case?
Well, look at this case,
here, and suppose for a moment
that you have a self
transition here.
Well in that case, you
would have a transition
from a white state
to a white state.
And you're not guaranteed
anymore that from a white state
you would go to a red state.
In that sense, as soon as
you have a self transition,
the Markov chain is aperiodic.
It cannot be periodic.
So whenever you have
a self transition,
this implies that the
chain is not periodic.
And usually that's the
simplest and easiest way
that we can tell,
most of the time,
that the chain is not periodic.